aber urlaub land präsentiert vorkommt
die krise spezialist für den ort
conti krieg punkt ch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
fünf tage 200 kilometer bis minus 20
grad
mit dem husky gespann quer durch die
wildnis lapplands vier frauen und ein
mann erfüllen sich einen traum
20 stunden dunkelheit eine reise die sie
an ihre grenzen bringt
[Musik]
aber auch ihr leben verändern wird
es ist schon eine so große berichtet
wird sich prägen
warum alles perfekt und es genau da auch
nicht wahnsinnig innerhalb von vier
tagen die kratzer
fünf tage zuvor das abenteuer startet
100 kilometer nördlich des polarkreises
auf der husky ranch von euroleague usa
im finnischen kotka co es ist anfang
dezember 2009 10
gemeinsam mit seiner frau hanna betreut
so hier 29 alaskan huskys hanna wird in
den nächsten tagen auf die ranch
aufpassen müssen ihr mann jo wird mit
den schweizer abenteurer unterwegs sein
die bedingungen auf meine ich würde es
lieber ein bisschen kälter habe aber ich
bin zufrieden dass die seen gefroren
sind die eis oder schneeschicht ist
immerhin 40 cm dick die trails sind
wirklich gut
das ist nicht selbstverständlich für
diese jahreszeit judo und hanna haben
seit 2009 schlittenhunde niveau fährt
zwei bis drei langstrecken rennen pro
winter mit ihnen doch meistens ist er in
dieser jahreszeit mit touristen
unterwegs fünftägige touren sind aber
eher selten
unsere hunde sind sehr sozial
sie brauchen die anderen hunde
aber auch unsere liebe wir haben ganz
verschiedene charaktere
manche sind ganz begeistert von neuen
menschen
andere sind etwas reservierter nicht
aggressiv einfach skeptisch wer ist
diese person die hunde verhalten sich
anders mit uns als mit den gästen
ist auch für judo und sein erstens eine
willkommene herausforderung
am anfang sind wir auf einfachen
streckenabschnitten die für
tagestouristen präpariert sind aber
weiter draußen gibt es dann kurvige hre
teile steilere
wir fahren durch gebüsch und wälder und
wenn wir glück haben gibt sogar einen
oder zwei schneestürme uns hier serie
heißt abenteuer lappland wird es ein
abenteuer definitiv das kann ich
versprechen
bevor das abenteuer morgen beginnt
spannt joho seine hunde für ihre
tägliche trainingsrunde vor sein
snowmobil huskies sind voller energie
und wollen vor allem eins rennen und in
der natur unterwegs sein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die schweizer gruppe ist unterdessen in
der dunkelheit lapplands angekommen
die vier frauen und ein mann haben sich
bis jetzt nicht bekannt
eine hr managerin und eine
physiotherapeutin eine software test
managerin der brunnenmeister aus giswil
und eine psychologin mit musikalische
ader
[Musik]
sie haben sich auf einen aufruf von sf
dok gemeldet was sie verbindet der
wunsch für fünf tage aus ihrem alltag
auszubrechen und die liebe zu hunden und
so natura platz bevor es losgeht die
letzte nacht in julias jahre zeit sich
besser kennenzulernen
vertriebsgeschäft bereich sanitär
heizung blick dass jetzt das auch einmal
mitarbeiter davon 450 muss man selbst
geschrieben habe und tore familie
riskiert hatte
doch darunter so soll ich malte dort
eine 23 ja und jetzt verbraucht bin eine
frohnatur und wie mies großes hobby und
liter schafft ist er wieder mit der
natur
ich bin schon mit mathematik sie die
frauen familie und jetzt aufgabe ist die
macht viele gern die aufgabe natürlich
sind zb von 3
schließlich sehe und ich die psychologin
reduzieren
die uni und da mache ich ganz mutig weg
investieren das sind die wochen zwischen
anderen machen wie ich wohne im aargau
wie somit eine landwirtschaftszone
großkonzerne der personalabteilung und
bedeute personal verantwortlich für die
region südostschweiz aus schwyz und
zürich also ein mit 30 tätigkeiten
bewundern in den arbeitsbereich und ich
habe die letzten eineinhalb jahre machte
mich selber investiert mit wieder
weniger europa nie die möglichkeit noch
einen schritt weiter das coni
verantworten
wem es halt so danke meinem büro sagt
jeder job ist das bringt das auch damit
sich der stress einfach das taktet mit
einer termine
das ist aber genau mit unserer
motivation sicherung
dann ist die sprache aus dem alter muss
eine schnelllebige ihnen umgebung wo
total anders ich bin nicht mehr gefahren
als spitzensportlerin der maxi und ich
liebte es nicht passt sich lieber
schnell ich bin gespannt wie es liebte
den pharma und erzählte mir macht sie
alles newzbin es wird spannend ist er
nicht wenn man denn jeder zahlt sind und
den wirklich -20 des kroatischen
bewegungen kocher und saaldorf stelle
ich freue mich lieber abend hier bis zum
aus der komfortzone golfclub es bringt
einfach wieder vom horizont ja noch
einiges dazulernen und so wie ein
gestreckter taille für hobbys und
traumjob software-managerin situation
mache das eigentlich mit herzblut fünf
jahren diagnose und eine verschlankung
parkinson ausbremsen
30 aktivität wieder zurück zu dir es
gibt hoffnung gibt mir kraft also dass
ein hof im raum in die natur und von der
natur wieder könne also was jetzt hier
und vertreten die körperliche zustand
wie dem schlächter nicht besser
medikament nehmen
das ist nicht stoppen sind nur symptom
kennedy verlauf nicht ich weiß nicht was
auf ihn zukommt und ganz große faktor
sie warum das ich mir spaß und ich hoffe
dass es immer noch lang so gut wie jetzt
haben wir mehr befragte als gut
dezember 2019 statt schnee und
minustemperaturen regen
[Musik]
wie vor jeder tour bekommen die runde am
morgen von newco besonders proteinreiche
nahrung
was sagst du zum wetter ich weiß nicht
ich kann gerade nichts sagen
eigentlich wären im dezember - gerade
normal aber auch hier oben in lappland
muss man sicher neue wettermuster
gewöhnen ich sah es leider schon den
ganzen herbst über hatten wir
temperaturschwankungen aber bis freitag
sollten wir wieder bei minus 16 grad
sein
unterdessen sind die schweizer auf der
farm angekommen
ihr seid also meine gruppe hallo
willkommen auf der husky grange ich
wünschte wir hätten besseres wetter ich
weiß ihr wollt die hunde treffen aber
zuerst werden wir euch bessere kleider
besorgen und dann werfen wir einen blick
auf die karte wo wir in den nächsten
fünf tagen unterwegs sein werden gehen
wir rein der regen ist schrecklich
habt ihr so was schon gemacht wie viel
erfahrung hat hier keine erfahrung keine
erfahrung halb tagestouren okay die
schönen die einfachen die mache ich
normalerweise auch tagestouren eine
einstündige tour
ok also wenigstens ein bisschen
erfahrung
das ganze ist einfach wenn der hunde
liebt und die natur dann ist das schon
mal ein guter start
denkt daran wir werden weit fahren
deshalb müssen wir als team zusammen
bleiben du darfst das team nicht
verlieren punkte wir fahren zuerst fünf
kilometer durch wald dann kommen wir in
dieses große naturreservat das größte
sumpfgebiete ruppert die tour beginnt
100 kilometer nördlich des polarkreises
in finnland von kurtág führt sie am
ersten tag 35 km durch das größte
sumpfgebiet europas in die wälder la
platz am zweiten tag folgen 46 kilometer
am dritten tag weitere 38 km mit dem
steilen anstieg auf den alice dem 3 und
am vierten tag folgt die königsetappe
mit über 50 kilometern den gleichen weg
zurück bevor es am fünften tag wieder
zurückgeht
[Musik]
inzwischen hat es aufgehört zu regnen
die teilnehmer lernen ihre hunde kennen
alle sind nett
er könnte überall hingehen keiner weiß
das wird ein hund sein silvia er wird
direkt vor dem schlitten laufen erst
stark may day wird in der mitte sein
das ist die mutter von medi die schwarze
erde
ich werde sie nicht ins erste team
nehmen sondern irgendwo in der mitte
[Musik]
sie wollen nur noch los das ist für sie
ein zeichen zum aufbruch
wenn leute in dieser kleidung her stehen
mayday ist erst einjährig und war noch
nie auf einer so langen tour nahm ihn
der brunnenmeister den großen starken
ballack
[Musik]
in flammen
fehler können wir sparen indem man
gerade für die bisherige tief liegt
charaktere bis 19 jahren
[Musik]
jede und jeder wird während der tour für
sein eigenes gespann mit fünf hunden
verantwortlich sein
zuerst heißt es schlitten packen mit
essen für sich und die hunde dem eigenen
gepäck und dem camping material
jeder schlitten wiegt so bis zu 60 kilo
auf der tour müssen sie die runde
versorgen camps aufbauen und vor allem
die kontrolle über das gespann nicht
verlieren wir gehen die fahrer
instruktionen durch wenn wir unterwegs
sind gibt es drei einfache zeichen dass
hier heißt langsam ihr bleibt mit dem
fuß auf der bremse platte
das heißt stopp steht auf die metall
bremse und wenn wir angehalten haben
müsst ihr auf der bremse bleiben wenn
die pause länger ist dann setzt er sogar
den brems anker aber auch der held nicht
sicher auch wenn wir anhalten behält ihn
im auge und wenn ihr grund was passieren
könnte das passiert immer wieder
wenn er also runter fällt und hier hängt
lässt nicht los
das ist die wichtigste reden lasst den
schlitten nicht los wartet bis die hunde
anhalten steht wieder auf die bremse
atme tief ein und fahrt weitere kleider
ab dann wird niemand wissen dass
heruntergefallen sein
wir spannen zuerst die lieder ein und
denkt dran
diese kleine kreaturen werden die seile
durch beißen wenn er nicht aufpasst
also schaut immer wieder dass die hunde
noch da sind ist die schwarze dahinten
armee dass die hunde nicht raus sie ihm
das geschirr in zwingern und kommt mit
einem hund hirns öffnen ich die türe
sonst rennen sie rausdrängen sie zurück
[Musik]
kaum sind die hunde eingespannt wollen
sie losrennen soho versucht alles unter
kontrolle zu behalten
[Musik]
dann endlich ruhe gibt es zeichen für
den start der tour die reihenfolge ist
klar definiert
jeder hat seine position doch
ausgerechnet bobfahrerin michelle kann
ihre runde nicht mehr zurückhalten
hey löse deine grenzen nicht zu früh
kontrollierten team ständig auf die
bremse
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dann endlich geht es los
es ist 12 uhr
[Musik]
und sie schlagen ist der anteil nicht
die hälfte plant stoff
[Musik]
und da ist es das gefühl von freiheit
davon haben sie alle geträumt eine
stimmung
speziell mystisch
[Musik]
die tage im dezember sind kurz nur vier
stunden dämmerlicht nach 2 uhr ein
erster stopp noch bevor die dunkelheit
hereinbricht essenspause auch für die
tiere wie geht es dir gut 15 kilometer
haben wir schon mittagspause auf sevilla
wird jo ein auge werfen wegen ihrer
parkinson erkrankung stellt die tour für
sie eine besondere herausforderung dar
dank medikamenten führt sie ein
weitgehend normales leben
ihr arzt gab grünes licht für die tour
pass auf dass die hunde nicht deine
leine durchbeißen
kannst du uns bitte helft new das sei
muss einige male warum dann der knoten
noch klappt nicht alles
sei vorsichtig mit den fingern
sie lieben diese berichte die runde
erhalten ein stück gefrorene wurst viel
arbeit an die sich das team noch
gewöhnen muss
[Musik]
die runde wollen weiter zurückgelegt
haben sie erst den halben weg keine
distanz für sie
dann etwas wovor sich jeder mascher
fürchtet einer von silvias hunden hat
sich am vorderlauf verletzt eine wunde
die verarztet werden muss damit hat die
hohen nicht gerechnet
schon am ersten tag ein solcher
zwischenfall noch weiß er nicht ob die
hündin zorn überhaupt weitermachen kann
weißt du was passiert ist
galliano muss irgendwo hängen geblieben
sein
es ist nur die haut sie hat keine
schmerzen
ich gebe etwas entzündungshemmendes ich
werde jetzt nicht auf die wunde tun
sie würde es nicht drauf lassen aber
wenn wir im camp sind dann werde ich
einen verband anlegen müssen
noch bleibt ihr in den sony im gespann
sie scheint auch begierig darauf weiter
zu rennen
hundeführerin silvia hatte die
verletzung selber nicht bemerkt
[Musik]
vielleicht hat sie einen ast oder sowas
gestreift irgendwie im vorbeigehen wenn
wir vom sumpf weg sind muss ich jemanden
anrufen dass sie mit dem schneemobil
abgeholt wird
es ist besser wenn sie eingeht zuerst
muss sich auch die gruppe noch stärken
der die kälte zehrt an den kräften
jetzt hast du nur noch einen führungs
von ca wir müssen es so versuchen wir
haben keine andere wahl
traurig wenn man schon so früh auf
wiedersehen sagen muss
judith sony vorerst in einer box
platzieren
die er hinter seinem schlitten her zieht
er nimmt das ganze gelassen
die verletzung scheint nicht allzu
schlimm aber er will keine infektion
riskieren
das ist nicht ganz wie ich es geplant
habe die box war für die alten oder die
ganz jungen gedacht nicht für die
verwundet sieht aber ziemlich nett
aussieht
lasst uns weitergehen bevor wir noch
mehr hunde in den krankenwagen partners
seite bereit
jetzt habe ich schon einen hund im wagen
verrücktes mädchen zu viel
geschwindigkeit und zu wenig helm
es muss weitergehen denn die gruppe ist
spät dran
es ist zwar erst 15 uhr doch schon
stockfinster
[Musik]
das abenteuer hat begonnen
kurz darauf wieder ein stopp-schild ihn
sony muss nach hause
[Musik]
ich glaube es geht ihr gut sie ist fast
eingeschlafen
vielleicht war sie einfach faul und
wollte sich einfach nur bequem machen
jetzt kann sie ein zu hanna vielleicht
auch sie sogar ins haus rein mein erstes
baby das heim muss so ein richtiger
profi
so war der start nicht geplant
ja
nun sind es nur noch 400 die silly us
schlitten ziehen müssen
allerdings seien diese vier stark genug
sagt die hoch
[Musik]
armin macht den schluss in der schlitten
kolonne seiner hunde sind die
kräftigsten aber auch die wildesten
nach drei stunden fahrt gegen 17 uhr das
erste nachtlager mitten im wald her sind
wir eher ist es schön
sucht euch alle einen baum
doch einer fehlt
armin glaube sich irgendwie nach hause
sich irgendein wunder schlägt ja sagen
wir ich glaube ebene stärken falsch war
und der shop zum glück passierte der
fehler so nah am etappenziel
so hat jo armins gespannt schnell
gefunden
als erstes müssen die runde verpflegt
werden gehört toni gewusst und sie war
mal ein bisschen buchhandel wurden so
wird es nach glühwein war was schmeckt
jeder hund sucht sich sein eigenes
plätzchen das bett und sie betonen sie
wir präparieren hunden hauptfleisch
das fleisch ist noch gefroren und musst
du erst aufgetaut werden muss alles
kontrollieren schon mal vor schaafs bis
zum die kiste muss voll wasser sein
zuerst kommt das fleisch rhein etwa zwei
drittel voll
dann füllte es bis oben mit heißem
wasser auf sonst wird das nicht weiß
[Musik]
gibt es ruhig auch den großen jungs und
wenn ihr ihnen das essen hinstellt passt
auf
kommt von einer seite perfekt abenteuer
lappland es bedeutet nicht nur romantik
sondern viel verantwortung
gegen 21 uhr die erste rast des tages
[Musik]
verkauft das so um dass und ichbezogen
besser
das ist einfach der start musste
zurückfindet meinte respektiert aber
bausachen der super klappt haben
reichlich im griff und dem ist enorm
steigern und dann doch bitte hin und her
läuft man tag sie sind daniel craig
zeugen diese die ganze anspannung und
freude und und und also irgendwie denn
richtig emotional zu mir emotional wurde
eigentlich so dass alles irgendwie so
die freude dass alle skeptischen
ist-besteuerung gegen notorische was
mache ich jetzt irgendwie so was mache
ich jetzt wieder erhöhen was mache ich
jetzt mit eingepackt und so ist also
plötzlich hilflos gefühlt erfahrung aber
ich glaube dass kommissar wieso der
nächste tag was sind dann weiß man muss
machen wir müssen zu machen das ist
richtig machen
ich bin froh waren so gut möglich oder
habt ihr angst habt das im oktober habe
aber ich war sehr beeindruckt mit dem
gemeinschaftszellen ich habe mein team
gefüttert und dann habe ich gedacht
soll ich hingehen und ihnen sagen sie
sollen das zelt aufstellen
das war schon da das füttern müssen wir
noch ein bisschen verbessern
da ist noch unsere schwachstellen aber
für das zelt gibt es schon mal fünf
punkte
es gibt diese heilige regel dass man
nicht ist bevor die hundefutter haben
sie haben das nicht gerne und werden
dich nicht mehr mögen
[Musik]
es ist morgens um halb sieben die nacht
war kalt
[Musik]
caffier
die hunde warten bereits hungrig auf ihr
fressen doch die abenteurer nehmen ist
gemütlich zum missfallen von newco
strophen war zwar an aber das muss
schneller
es sollte immer jemand hier sein und
schauen dass ständig schnee schmilzt das
ist immer feuer hat es ist der erste
morgen darum lasse ich das noch
durchgehen aber das hier müsste erste
priorität haben und ich gebe euch noch
eine t
es ist schön warm rufen kein schlechter
platz wenn du aus dem kalten zeit kommen
vorsichtig damit ihr nicht die ganze
stunde arbeit zunichte macht die runde
kommen zuerst und dann die teilnehmer
und jede minute verzögerung am morgen
bedeutet weniger tageslicht während dazu
[Musik]
das messer immer als erstes machen das
wasser schmelz erst nachher geht er auf
toilette und putz die zähne der ofen
hier muss immer brennen wenn das
schmelzen geht lange so als machen wir
noch kaffee dass armin aufwacht so gut
ich würde das auch gerne essen aber ist
es die heute anpackt nur wenig ja die
hunde bekommen rohes fleisch mit hohem
fettgehalt dazu kommen auch getrocknete
protein stücke
an diese routine müssen sich alle erst
gewöhnen denn sie haben die
verantwortung für die tiere
[Musik]
9 uhr 30
eigentlich wollte juror bereits
unterwegs sein
die hunde sind unruhig sie wollen los
die hunde sind sehr oft geladen sie
wollen rennen
ich rechne damit dass irgendetwas
passiert damit alle für den restlichen
tag noch ein team haben bleibe ich hier
um sie allenfalls zu stoppen
[Musik]
und tatsächlich julius vorahnung
bewahrheitet sich rasch so winters bei
armin herrscht aufregung
[Applaus]
armins rüden ballack und cooper geraten
in einen kampf wir hatten ja gerade ein
krampf du musst strenger sein kann ich
immer dazwischen die geh nicht mit den
händen rein wenn sie kämpfen aber sagt
stock du bist der chef
es dauert alles solange die hunde werden
nervös
ich habe eben zu allen gesagt dass er
sie nicht streiten lassen da du musst
streng sein wenn du spürst der ton wird
zu aggressiv musst du das sofort stoppen
wenn sie sich für zehn minuten anbringen
kann es aushalten das mache die hängen
also bis ja das sind sie aber kein
meister mehr das sagen dass ich von
guten trend psychische linie aber die
anderen drei sind aus
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dann endlich gegen 11 uhr zwei stunden
zu spät geht es los in die zweite etappe
[Musik]
immer tiefer und tiefer in die wildnis
lapplands wo weitere abenteuer auf sie
warten
[Musik]
deutschland präsentiert von conti kreise
ein spezialist für die nazis in nord
conti krieg punkt ch